Hi Michael.
>> Hi Charles, How's it going?
>> It's going quite well,
how's it going with you?
>> Not too bad.
What are we going to talk about today?
>> Well what does the screen say?
>> It looks like a wordle.
>> Yes it's a wordle.
It's generalizing generalizing and
the key words are.
>> Abstraction, scale, search.
>> What we're going to do is I'm
going to try to jump off from some of
the discussions that we had earlier
that you lead, about generalization.
And try to sort of hop up a level above
that and talk about abstraction and
scale and search and sort of the things
that make machine learning and
reinforcement learning,
in particular, hard.
>> Okay, so, but it seems to me that I
talked about function approximation,
and everything is
a function approximation.
So, why is there more to say?
>> Well, we'll find out.
That's the whole point
of today's lesson.
>> [LAUGH] All right.
>> Okay, so, let's get going.